so far 2022 has been a great year for
games this means you've probably had
some awesome experiences but you
probably also have a handful of new
additions to your backlog not to worry
though because even though april has
some great games as well it's a little
slower than january through march so
here are all the big games that you can
look forward to playing in the month of
april and spoiler alert switch owners
are getting a lot
lego star wars games are nothing new but
until now none have attempted to pack in
the entire nine movies of the skywalker
saga originally slated for release in
spring 2021 lego star wars the skywalker
saga is a whole new game and not merely
just a collection of the previous lego
star wars games all of the missions will
be fresh for returning players and
you'll be able to start from any point
in the saga so if you really hate the
prequels even in game form then feel
free to ignore them entirely the game
also features nearly 500 characters from
the star wars universe and many of them
are playable by far my favorite new
additions to the series are character
skill trees cover based shooting
mechanics and a melee combo system lego
star wars the skywalker saga is coming
to a galaxy far far away on all consoles
and pc on april 5th
it was a little weird last year to see a
playstation studios logo pop up on an
xbox game it was even weirder when the
game was a day 1 release on game pass
and now the weirdness can continue when
that logo splashes up on a nintendo
switch screen mlb the show 2022 will
feature full cross play for all consoles
involved as well as cross progression
support that means you'll be able to
play your game pass copy and then take
it on the go via the switch and be able
to pick up in your season right where
you left off this save progression will
be done using an mlb the show account
which shouldn't be a pain to set up mlb
the show 2022 will be sliding into home
plate aka every console on april 5th
this upcoming switch title is a remaster
of the 1999 rpg chrono cross complete
with several quality of life changes
such as the ability to skip battles and
a newly refined high quality soundtrack
in addition to chrono cross the game
also includes radical dreamers a
text-based adventure game that served as
a supplemental title to chrono trigger
and was originally released on the super
famicom other new features include 3d
models converted to hd refined character
illustrations battle enhancements to
make combat easier and resolution
changes among other things chrono cross
the radical dreamers edition will
release on playstation 4 xbox one switch
and pc on april 7th
appropriately titled the house of the
dead remake this game is being published
by forever entertainment and promises to
be true to the original gameplay however
the game does offer a second mode for
fans that want to switch things up no
pun intended this mode is called horde
and is considered a fast-paced
modernized mode with up to 50 times more
monsters and unlockable rewards to
collect and similar to many other games
on nintendo's hybrid console house of
the dead will be playable using the
joy-con analog sticks or using gyroscope
functionality the house of the dead
franchise began its life as a light gun
series in arcades before later coming to
other platforms including dreamcast its
last main release was house of the dead
scarlet dawn in 2018 which was never
released outside of arcades and there
have also been spin-offs such as the
typing of the dead the house of the dead
remake comes back to life on april 7th
for nintendo switch
originally released for ps4 in 2019 for
japan and 2020 for us 13 sentinels is
now making its way onto nintendo switch
the game can be described as a
side-scrolling adventure game with
real-time strategy battles in our review
for the game heidi kemps called it a
unique genre mixing experiment that
takes elements of point-and-click
adventure games visual novels real-time
strategy games and tower defense games
to create an experience that's quite
unlike anything else out there another
way to help describe 13 sentinels is how
its gameplay is split into three
sections remembrance that focuses on
exploration and dialogue destruction
where the rts battles take place and
analysis a glossary of important info
about characters and items in the game
one thing's for sure you won't have to
worry about a lack of content here 13
sentinels drops on april 12th for
nintendo switch
just when you thought one star wars game
in april was enough 2008 star wars the
force unleashed returns to a nintendo
console in this wii port of the game
you'll play as darth vader's apprentice
starkiller and do everything in your
power to serve him on a quest to destroy
the jedi similar to the wii this version
of the game uses motion controls to help
the character feel more at one with the
force and features a dual mode so you
can hand a joy-con to a friend and then
destroy them in a 1v1 battle the
re-release of the force unleashed will
be unleashed on april 20th
motogp is back for 2022 with motogp 2022
and with it comes a handful of new
features to make it more exciting for
fans and newcomers for example moto gp
features a revised tutorial with custom
rules to help new players better
understand the game's basic mechanics
and once you're done with that the game
also offers a new moto gp academy to
help players improve their riding these
new steps towards more approachability
goes even farther when you factor in the
game's new adaptive difficulty system
moto gp 2020 is racing to a console or
pc near you on april 21st
when i read that the serpent rogue is an
action adventure game set in a medieval
fantasy world i was instantly drawn to
it and when i discovered the player is
tasked with saving the lands from an
ominous danger i knew i had to try the
demo on steam in the serpent rogue
you'll craft and brew your way to
becoming a master of alchemy all while
exploring a mythical land and fighting
all types of monsters the serpent rogue
is mixing up some potions on april 26th
for playstation 5 xbox series x and s
switch and pc
during the february 2022 direct nintendo
revealed switch sports a follow-up to
wii sports if you have fond memories of
the originals tennis and bowling games
then you're going to be very happy with
nintendo switch sports like its
predecessor switch sports delivers a
bunch of different sports to play all of
which are played with motion controls
six games will be included initially and
unlike the original wii sports nintendo
switch sports will feature online play
so you can compete against friends and
random challenges a golf game will be
added as a free update i managed to jump
into one of the network test sessions
last month and all i can say is that i
crushed everyone i went up against so if
you see me online when the full game
drops i'd suggest you leave that lobby
nintendo switch sports will bring out
everyone's competitive side on april
29th
there you have it a list of april's
biggest games somewhat dominated by
switch releases some other games that
didn't make this list include the
console version of road 96 on april 14th
and zombie army 4 also coming to switch
on april 26th so what game are you most
excited for let us know in the comments
below and while you're there let us know
what game you'd love to see announced in
april thanks for watching
[Music]
you